on sunday an exploding fireball so great
it could be seen 100 kilometers away in
havana
but by tuesday evening the smoke had
turned from soot black to light grey
evidence that much of the large fire at
cuba's main oil depot was out
but with a thick toxic smog over the
city of matansas people are still
worried
you on the side i'm covered up because i
see the clouds i smell the sulfur and i
don't want this to affect me in the
future
we're expecting the situation to worsen
the oil everything that was lost or
damaged like oil reserves everything
will be harder now
the cuban air force used helicopters
manufactured in the soviet era to douse
the flames
but more modern technology was needed
mexico and venezuela sending more than
100 specialists technology and tons of
extinguishing foam
but material supports did not come from
the united states upsetting many
the us offered technical assistance but
in the end we haven't seen anything
concrete
i think it's a lack of humanity above
all because we're not talking about a
political issue we're talking about a
humanitarian issue
in the 2020 u.s presidential campaign
trail joe biden had promised to reverse
the sanctions former president donald
trump imposed on the island
but in office the bulk of them have
remained in place including sanctions on
oil tankers which aggravate the island's
energy crisis
legal experts say u.s law does not
prevent the united states from providing
material assistance
four days after a lightning strike hit
cuba's biggest oil storage facility the
blaze finally seems to be under control
but analysts say the loss of four
supertankers will only aggravate cuba's
already critical energy crisis
with most flames extinguished rescue
workers have now entered the disaster
zone for the first time to search for
missing firefighters
and while the lights are still on for
some
cuba's energy crisis is set to become
critical
ed augustine al jazeera matanzas cuba